[Music]
it's been such a strange difficult year
so many ups and downs we've been pushed
to our limits
but things are about to get much easier
a massive lifting of covered
restrictions
just one week away the hard
work worth it your efforts have so
visibly
paid off giving us the time to vaccinate
more than two-thirds of all adults
across the uk
and so it's precisely because of your
efforts that
i can confirm today that we've met our
four
tests for further easing the lockdown
in england a time to celebrate this
means the rule of six
or two households that is applied
outdoors
will now apply indoors and the limit for
outdoor meetings will increase
to 30 from next monday you'll be able to
sit inside a pub
and inside a restaurant you'll be able
to go to the cinema
and children will be able to use indoor
play areas
students returning to university no face
masks required in schools
and a shift of responsibility the
government more hands
and we can all be a bit more hands-on
with the risk that entails
today we're taking a step towards that
moment
when we learn to live responsibly with
kovid
when we cease eventually to rely on
detailed government edicts and make our
own
decisions so from next monday we're
updating the guidance
on close contact between friends and
family
setting out the risks for everyone to
make
their own choices garden parties friends
and family around your kitchen table
a drink inside the pub in an overnight
stay
finally after a very long year something
like normal life not just a hope
it's almost a reality so this a big step
forward
a big improvement in our everyday lives
but it comes with a bit of a risk too
because this pandemic
is not yet over but in barnley people
are looking forward to the end
well i'm still alive and my town is
coming back to life so
as far as i'm concerned they've done all
right by me when i get back some
normality now get on an holiday
i've had two corbett vaccines now so
it's i'm all good to go me
reopening stuff and getting things back
to where it was people are now getting
more jobs
so people are now starting to work again
and getting more income and you know
we're kind of going back to our old life
again
old life but with new threats this virus
and evolving enemy
new variants could threaten our progress
and if science can't keep a lid on it
it'll be up to us again to sacrifice our
freedoms
to protect life beth rigby sky news
westminster